قبل بدء النشره وقبل تفاصيلها مشاهدينا
نتابع معكم كلمه للرئيس الاوكراني
عبر الفيديو من كييف امام مؤتمر ميونخ
للامن
ز
تسبوا وضع
الدوله مرشحه ونحن نستعد الان للتفاوض في
العضويه
ونحن موحدين مع الاقتصاد الاوروبي
واللوجستيات والطاقه فما من بديل لنا
النصر الاوكراني لا بديل لاوكرانيا
وفي الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يوجد
لمديل الا ان تكون اوكرانيا في النيتو
لا بديل لوحدتنا
وبالتالي
لابد ان لا يكون هناك
بديل للتخلص كليا من روسيا وتحرير الارض
والشعب الا اننا في كل مدينه وقريه تحت
الاحتلال سيبقى الشعب فيها
تحت الاحتلال لابد وهذا امر لا نتنازل فيه
بل لابد من تحرير اوكرانيا كامله عندما
يطلق الروس النار علينا فهم يوجهونه ايضا
على دول الجوار هل تتنازل اوروبا كلا بل
لابد من التحرر من العدوان الروسي فهذا
يهدد كل دوله اوروبيه ويؤثر على الاقتصاد
الاوروبي والعالمي عندها فقط سيكون هناك
فرصه للحريه على حدودنا الشرقيه هل
سيكونون ايضا
عرضه لمثل هذه مثل هذا التنازل كلا بل نحن
سنبقى
مستمرين ومواصلين لننتصر ليس فقط
بوتين وروسيا بل
لابد من تكريسي
قوتي مفهوم الحريه سيداتي وسادتي ان العزم
لدينا
لم يتهاون
تمت هزيمه قواتهم
ليس بسبب قوه الجيش بل بسبب الشجاعه
والوطنيه
والشجاعه هي ما لدينا ولدينا الكثير منها
ليس في اوكرانيا فقط بل هذا لا بد ان
يتضاخم الان منذ العام الماضي كنا هنا في
ميونخ
لنتحدث في اعصاب الحرب حول
شروط اوكرانيا الحره واوروبا الحره
والعالم الحر
بكل اصدقائنا
وحلفائنا
اعتقد
انكم وصلتم الفكره واشكركم جزيل الشكر على
حسن الاهتمام وحسن الاصغاء
انتم
من العالم الحر
ونحن
نحارب من اجل العالم الحر وسننتصر ضد
بوتين والمجد لكل من هم في ساحه المعركه
شكرا لكم
نقلنا
نقلنا لكم مشاهدينا جانبا لكلمه رئيس
الاوكراني فولدمير زيلينس في عبر الفيديو
امام مؤتمر ميونخ للامن طبعا شدد فيه
زيلينسكي على اهميه انضمام اوكرانيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو وجدد المطالبه
باسلحه وطائرات مقاتله في اسرع وقت ممكن